OF COURSE THERE IS ONE OBVIOUS
SOLUTION, FIRE MARY BARRA.
FOR YEARS LIBERAL CITIES AND
STATES HAVE BEEN CLAIMING THE
RIGHT TO IGNORE FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION LAW.
NOW ONE SMALL TOWN POLICE CHIEF
IN WASHINGTON STATE IS SAYING
THE SAME PRINCIPLE CAN BE
APPLIED TO FAR-REACHING GUN LAW
LAWS.
A NEW GUN-CONTROL ORDINANCE IN
WASHINGTON IMPOSES STRICTER
BACKGROUND CHECKS, RAISES THE
AGE FOR BUYING A SEMIAUTOMATIC
RIFLE AND ALLOWS GUN OWNERS TO
BE CRIMINALLY PROSECUTED IF THE
FIREARMS ARE STOLEN OR USED
ILLEGALLY.
HE SAYS HE WANTS HIS TOWN TO BE
A SANCTUARY FROM THESE NEW GUN
LAWS.
SOME OF THE LOCAL RESIDENTS
IMPOSE, OPPOSE THE NEW MEASURE.
>> OPPONENTS SAY IT ALLOWS GUN
OWNERS TO SECURE THEM IN A WAY
THAT COULD BE DANGEROUS.
>> YOU'RE NOT GOING TO TELL THE
CRIMINAL, COULD YOU HOLD ON FOR
A MOMENT BECAUSE I HAVE A LOT  I
A MOMENT BECAUSE I HAVE A LOT  T
LOCKED AND I HAVE TO SAFELY
STORE IT SOMEWHERE.
>> YOU CALL POLICE AND THINGS GO
DOWN, THAT'S LESS THAN ONE
MINUTE AND THE SECONDS COUNT.
>> Tucker: CHIEF, THANKS VERY
MUCH FOR COMING ON.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> GOOD EVENING, TUCKER, THANKS
FOR HAVING ME.
>> SO IS THIS IN FACT THE
SANCTUARY FOR THE GUN LAWS OF
YOUR STATE?
>> I HAVE SUGGESTED AN ORDINANCE
AND RECOMMENDED IT TO THE
CITY COUNCIL AND IF THEY ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING THAT
AND DOING THEIR DUE DILIGENCE TO
SEE IF THEY WANT TO PASS THAT.
AS FAR AS THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
GOES, WE WILL NOT BE ENFORCING
THAT.
>> Tucker: SUBSIDIES THAT HAVE
DECIDED TO IGNORE FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION LAW HAVE RECEIVED
THE APPLAUSE AND SUPPORT OF
ALMOST EVERYONE ON THE AMERICAN
LEFT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE RESPONSE
WILL BE IF YOU ARE TOWN PASSES
THIS ORDINANCE?
>> I DON'T THINK THE SAME PEOPLE
WOULD BE VERY HAPPY.
THE THING ABOUT IT IS, ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ARE COVERED BY THE
BILL OF RIGHTS AND THE
CONSTITUTION AND GUN OWNERS ARE.
>> Tucker: A VERY GOOD POINT.
SO WHAT WILL HAPPEN NEXT?
WILL THE GOVERNOR OF THE STATE
TRY TO FORCE YOU TO ENFORCE THE
LAW THAT YOU THINK IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL?
>> WELL I DON'T KNOW HOW IT
COULD, TUCKER.
WE LIVE IN A CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC, CONTRARY TO WHAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE TELL US, THAT WE LIVE
IN A DEMOCRACY.
BUT WE HAVE THE RULE OF LAW IN
THIS STATE AND THE
UNITED STATES, AND THE
CONSTITUTION IS THE LAW OF THE
LAND.
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT THE
SECOND AMENDMENT SAYS, A LOT OF
YOUR VIEWERS MAY NOT KNOW WHAT
THE WASHINGTON STATE
CONSTITUTION SAYS ABOUT FIREARMS
BUT QUICKLY IT SAYS THE RIGHT OF
THE INDIVIDUAL CITIZEN TO BEAR
ARMS AGAINST HIMSELF OR THE
STATE SHALL NOT BE IMPAIRED.
SO I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY CAN GET
AROUND THAT AND TRY TO FORCE ME
TO GO AGAINST MY OATH OF OFFICE
TO UPHOLD THAT.
>> Tucker: IT THAT'S
INTERESTING.
IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S ALREADY
BEING IGNORED.
SO REALLY QUICKLY, THE STATE LAW
WOULD REQUIRE GUN OWNERS TO KEEP
THEIR GUNS LOCKED UP AT ALL
TIMES.
>> IT REQUIRES YOU TO KEEP IT
LOCKED UP BECAUSE IF SOMEONE
GAINS ACCESS TO YOUR GUN, SAY
YOU ARE AWAY FROM HOME AND
SOMEONE BREAKS IN AND STEALS
YOUR GUN, AND THEN COMMITS A
CRIME WITH IT, YOU COULD BE
CHARGED WITH A FELONY FOR THAT
PERSON GETTING HER GUN AND
COMMITTING A CRIME.
>> CHARGING SOMEONE WHO HAS YOUR
CAR STOLEN, IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> THAT IS RIDICULOUS.
AND GOOD FOR YOU FOR FIGHTING
BACK AGAINST IT.